os habéis dado cuenta de que América
Latina es desde el punto de vista
político social una de las regiones más
homogéneas de todo el mundo
en Latinoamérica la mayoría de los
países tienen el mismo idioma la
religión católica es mayoritaria y casi
todos tienen una historia común aunque
solo sea porque la mayoría de ellos
nacieron tras independizarse del imperio
español y en el caso de Brasil con
ciertos matices propios lógicamente el
camino pues viene a ser en cierta forma
muy similar fijaos si no en la política
latinoamérica comparte una cultura de
gobierno presidencialista con liderazgos
que van desde la derecha hasta la
izquierda pero que suelen tener muy
frecuentemente un ingrediente común el
populismo Así que En definitiva en
términos sociopolíticos podemos decir
que los países que integran esta región
son en el peor de los casos primos
hermanos sin embargo todos estos
parecidos y todos estos lazos tienen un
límite muy pero que muy claro la
economía sorprendentemente en el terreno
económico la región está muy poco
integrada y la variedad de políticas es
enorme desde la prudencia inquebrantable
en el control de las cuentas públicas
del Perú hasta el comunismo de Cuba
pasando por el populismo del blockchain
en El Salvador o la adicción al dinero
del Banco Central del gobierno argentino
sin embargo pese a todo sabíais que
desde hace décadas existen numerosos
proyectos para que la tenga más ni menos
que una moneda común veremos acaso en
hacer el euro latino pues atentos
Por cierto importantísimo si os gustan
los temas económicos no os podéis perder
bajo ningún concepto nuestro canal
hermano visual económico en ellos
hablamos de temas tan interesantes como
el salario mínimo Cómo están funcionando
las sanciones contra Rusia o Qué
problemas puede tener la dolarización de
un país si aún no lo conocéis echad un
vistazo y contadnos que os parece ya
somos más de 250.000 miembros en esta
nueva comunidad os dejo el enlace en la
descripción y también al final de este
vídeo pero dicho esto continuamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos amigas No creo que tenga
que convenceros de esta idea la moneda
es un elemento esencial clave
fundamental en toda economía Claro que
pesa yo no todos los estados tienen su
propia moneda en el mundo Existen
algunas áreas monetarias que integran a
más de un país la pertenencia una de
estas áreas monetarias implica que los
países miembros se dan una parte de su
soberanía y adopten una moneda común
bien sea para el día a día o en el caso
más limitado para relacionarse
comercialmente entre los países miembros
Esto es algo que fundamentalmente puede
producirse de dos maneras distintas
primero está el caso de las uniones
formales y pactadas como ocurre por
ejemplo en la Unión Europea y el euro y
por otro está el caso de las uniones
informales en adoptar unilateralmente
una moneda extranjera es decir en este
caso se cede la soberanía monetaria a un
tercer país cuyo Banco Central sea
percibido como más fiable esto es por
ejemplo el caso de países personalizados
como Ecuador o Panamá
sea como sea no hablamos de procesos que
podrán desarrollarse de la noche a la
mañana especialmente si hablamos de las
uniones formales en este caso para que
la cosa funcione tienen que darse una
serie de condiciones estas condiciones
son más o menos las que todos podemos
imaginarnos una tasa de inflación baja
un déficit presupuestario controlado a
niveles de deuda ajustados y política de
tipos similares ahora bien tranquilos
que no Vamos a ponernos muy teóricos con
este tema nos basta con saber que son
las grandes rasgos de las áreas
monetarias y ahora que ya lo sabemos la
pregunta es qué tal fueron los
experimentos latinoamericanos para
avanzar por este camino Pues bien
veamoslo
Centroamérica un proyecto pionero pero
estancado
el 25 de febrero de 1964 Costa Rica El
Salvador Guatemala Honduras y Nicaragua
escribieron el conocido como acuerdo
para el establecimiento de la unión
monetaria centroamericana con este
acuerdo amigos estos países se instaban
a sus respectivos bancos centrales a
integrarse en un sistema de bancos
centrales Centroamericanos que sería
conducido por el consejo monetario
centroamericano los mecanismos de
cooperación establecidos por los bancos
centrales señalan la necesidad y la
oportunidad de adoptar medidas
pendientes a realizar por etapas la
integración monetaria de Centroamérica
cuarto punto del acuerdo para el
establecimiento de la unión monetaria
centroamericana de 1964 Sin embargo a
pesar de ser una iniciativa pionera en
la región Las Guerras civiles
centroamericanas truncaron por completo
este proyecto bueno Y es que de hecho
sumergieron a estos países en
larguísimos procesos de violencia
política como por ejemplo ocurrió con la
revolución sandinista de Nicaragua
no obstante sin embargo en 1974 se logró
un nuevo acuerdo monetario regional un
primer paso que fue nuevamente
modificado en los 90 para relanzar un
consejo monetario común encabezado por
los presidentes de los bancos centrales
de Costa Rica El Salvador Guatemala
Honduras y Nicaragua Pues bien el
objetivo de este relanzado órgano era
fundamentalmente asesorar a los
diferentes gobiernos para avanzar con
las reformas que hacían falta para
establecer de una vez por todas la tan
ansiada moneda común el consejo
promoverá la estrecha coordinación y
armonización de las políticas monetarias
con las políticas Fiscales de
integración y de desarrollo económico de
los países Centroamericanos artículo 39
del acuerdo monetario centroamericano de
1999 más tarde en el año 2002 se unió a
este acuerdo en la República Dominicana
pero de la moneda única nunca más se
supo y de hecho por ejemplo El Salvador
dolalizó su economía en el año 2000 hoy
este órgano con sede en San José Costa
Rica es básicamente un foro de diálogo
Pero oye Tenemos que tener en cuenta
aquí fue un proyecto surgido los años 60
fue una iniciativa realmente pionera Al
menos que se lleve ese crédito
[Música]
el socialismo del Siglo 21 contra La
dictadura del dólar según cálculos de la
reserva Federal entre los años 1999 y
2019 el dólar supuso el 96% de toda la
facturación comercial en el continente
americano una región donde ni el rublo
ni el yuan y el euro ni ninguna otra
moneda han podido desplazar al papel
moneda del Tío Sam Por supuesto Esto no
es algo malo sin embargo para los
arquitectos del socialismo del siglo XXI
esto no era sino la dictadura del dólar
algo que por supuesto resultaba
absolutamente intolerable para el
referente de este movimiento Hugo Chávez
quien se lanzó a todo una Cruzada contra
el billete verde a pesar de que luego en
el terreno personal pues le encantarán
los billetes del tío el Imperio del
dólar viene el mundo es víctima del
imperio del dólar entre tantos un día me
dijo Fidel Castro Chávez mira y Estados
Unidos ha comprado medio mundo con puros
papeles papeles que no tienen
sustentación económica pues llegó la
hora nosotros tenemos la idea y por
primera vez la voy a comentar en público
de una moneda internacional que a mí Me
emocionas la sola idea el Petro Pues
bien El caso es que para ponerle fin a
esta supuesta dictadura monetaria el
chavismo tenía en mente diferentes vías
para eludir el uso del dólar en sus
transacciones comerciales
y finalmente en 2009 se optó por
implantar un sistema unitario de
compensación regional Generalmente
nombrado por sus siglas el sucre En
referencia al profesor independentista
latinoamericano Antonio José de sucre
octubre de 2009 Venezuela y Bolivia
estrenan el sucre ambos países
estrenarán el nuevo sistema de
compensación de pagos creado el pasado
fin de semana por los países de la Alba
como nos dice su nombre este mecanismo
no era una moneda en sí mismo sino más
bien un sistema de pagos donde se
establecía un tipo de cambio de 1,25
dólares por cada sucre algo que venía
desacoplar el uso de la divisa
norteamericana en las importaciones y
exportaciones de los países integrados
en este esquema es decir operaba
sencillamente de manera simbólica pero
Oye técnicamente ya no operaban en
dólares de esta forma en la unidad se
cuenta común del Banco Central de cada
país no se registraban los ingresos en
dólares sino que se hacía en sucres Pese
a que a su vez esto sucre es equivalían
a una cierta cantidad de dólares que En
definitiva es lo que le daba valor no sé
un Galicia es un tanto absurdo
inicialmente este sistema fue
implementado por la alianza bolivariana
para los miembros del Alba una
organización en la cual participaban
Venezuela Cuba Bolivia Ecuador y
Nicaragua vamos lo mejor de cada casa
sucre es un sistema único de
compensación regional y eso comenzará
haciendo una moneda virtual desde el año
2010 el aparato de propaganda chavista
difundió la idea de sucre A los cuatro
vientos lo pintaban como un mecanismo
ideal un mecanismo que podría dar lugar
incluso a una nueva moneda con la
proyección de sustituir al mismísimo
dólar en un plazo relativamente corto de
tiempo
septiembre de 2011 Chávez Llama a crear
moneda latinoamericana ante dictadura
del dólar sin embargo amigos amigas
mecanismo Nunca logró desarrollarse como
moneda y quedó estancado como un sistema
alternativo para sortear teatralmente el
uso del dólar a pesar de que Hugo Chávez
insistió una y otra y otra vez hasta el
hartazgo con este tema El sucre algún
día el sucre yo me imagino que el sucre
será físico Rafael moneda física porque
no hasta ahora espiritual pero yo quiero
Oye que mi palabra ojalá pueda
incentivar a que Juguemos duro con el
sucre no seamos mezquinos es un
mecanismo maravilloso ustedes lo conocen
nos estamos liberando de qué de la
dictadura del dólar a nivel
internacional Por cierto fue Rafael
Correa quien acabamos de ver juntas
Chávez quien condujo uno de los países
que más utilizó el sucre con mucha
diferencia
[Música]
entre los años 2011 y 2016 Ecuador
ejecutó al menos 6.319 transacciones
mediante esquema las cuales sumaron casi
3.000 millones de dólares y es que al
parecer los políticos en este país Pues
digamos que supieron darle un uso algo
más beneficioso atentos lo que en un
inicio se planteó como un sistema
multilateral de compensación de pagos en
la realidad operó como un mecanismo de
exportaciones en su mayoría ficticias y
sobrevaloradas en su mayoría de Ecuador
a Venezuela y que adicionalmente sirvió
para canalizar operaciones relacionadas
con el lavado de dinero enriquecimiento
ilícito y peculado fragmento del informe
de la comisión especializada permanente
de fiscalización y control político que
como os habéis quedado seguro que esa no
la esperabais El caso es que por este
motivo desde el año 2015 tanto la
justicia ecuatoriana como distintas
investigaciones del legislativo de este
país han identificado diferentes tramas
de lavado de activos mediante el uso
precisamente del sucre el cual Por
cierto al final terminó como casi todas
las promesas del numeroso socialismo del
siglo XXI entre expectativas a la deriva
y novedosas herramientas para ampliar la
corrupción
[Música]
y cautela el mercado integrado en
latinoamericano Mila bien antes de
continuar tenemos que hacer un breve
paréntesis la integración económica en
Sudamérica tiene esencialmente dos caras
una es el mercado común del sur El
conocido habitualmente como mercosur una
organización integrada por Argentina
Uruguay Brasil Paraguay y Venezuela
aunque esta última se encuentra
suspendida desde el 2019 y la otra es la
alianza del Pacífico en la cual
participan Perú Colombia México y chile
Pues bien es esta última la que en el
año 2011 formó el mercado integrado
latinoamericano el conocido como Mila
este proyecto tampoco es una moneda en
sí misma ni siquiera es un sistema de
pagos en la alianza del Pacífico las
cosas están tomando con mucha calma y el
primer paso hacia una auténtica
integración financiera y económica se
dio mediante esta iniciativa donde no se
unifican monedas sino mercados de
capitales Pues bien actualmente este
proyecto reúna más de 700 compañías de
este bloque económico el cual representa
un mercado que abarca más del 40% de
todo el pib de latinoamérica y el Caribe
y el 38% del total de los flujos una
inversión extranjera directa en la zona
y hay que decir que por el momento aquí
no existe ningún proyecto concreto de
Unión monetaria pero la estabilidad de
los miembros de la alianza y su mayor
grado de apertura y Libertad económica
respecto por ejemplo a los integrantes
del mercosur hacen que no parezca
descabellado que en un futuro no muy
lejano los países miembros puedan
avanzar Precisamente en esta dirección
pero aún no hemos terminado Así que
sigamos
[Música]
las apuestas más recientes entre el
tango y la samba
en abril del 2019 Se confirmó una
importante reunión entre el entonces
ministro de economía argentino Nicolás
dujofre y su par brasileño Paulo wedes
la reunión se celebró en Washington en
medio de una agenda de citas con el fmi
y el Banco Mundial en aquel encuentro
amigos ambos funcionarios hablaron sobre
el peso real una moneda como un
gestionada por Brasilia y Buenos Aires a
la cual podrían llegar a sumarse los
demás países del mercosur tener una
moneda común en toda latinoamérica Sería
muy bueno creo que en 15 años habrá
cuatro o cinco grandes monedas en el
mundo en 15 años va a existir el dólar
el euro el redmi chino y ojalá allí este
el peso real creo que vamos a desembocar
en una moneda común a futuro Paulo
Guedes en julio de 2019 Sin embargo
apenas unos meses después de estar
atrevida propuesta Mauricio macri fue
derrotado en las elecciones
presidenciales y un nuevo gobierno
asumió el poder en Argentina y entonces
el proyecto quedó por completo congelado
entre otras cosas porque Fernández y
bolsonaro no es que se llevarán
particularmente bien
bolsonarri Fernández intercambian
insultos a pesar de la interdependencia
de Brasil y Argentina pero hubo un
momento porque así como las elecciones
sacaron el tema de la agenda en
Argentina otras elecciones volvieron a
traer la idea de una moneda común esta
vez en Brasil atentos
el sur una moneda como Promesa de
campaña
el banquero Gabriel galípolo y el ex
candidato presidencial del partido del
trabajo Fernando hadad el cual Por
cierto fue Derrotado por bolsonaro en
2018 hicieron pública la idea de crear
el sur una moneda regional que sería
emitida por un Banco Central
sudamericano este banco sería
constituido mediante la aportación de
Divisas por sus países miembros en
proporción a sus respectivas
participaciones en el comercio regional
la capitalización se haría con las
reservas internacionales de los países y
o con un impuesto a las exportaciones de
los países fuera de la región la nueva
moneda podría utilizarse tanto para el
comercio como para los flujos
financieros entre países de la región
Fernando adad y Gabriel gallipolo en
mayo de este año y ahora el mismo Lula
da Silva ha mencionado este tema
integrándolo además como parte de su
campaña presidencial fijaos si Dios
quiere vamos a crear una moneda en
América Latina porque no nos podemos
quedar dependiendo del dólar Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva en principio el
sur es algo más complejo Que el peso
real pero la principal diferencia es que
ahora la Argentina ya aquí el soñador
país del 2019
este año el peso argentino es una de las
monedas que más está devaluando en todo
el mundo con una infracción esperada en
2022 de cerca del 100% y quizás por eso
en julio de este mismo año el entonces
ministro argentino de desarrollo
productivo mencionó exactamente esto
hable más de una hora con el ministro
Guedes y un punto central de la
conversación fue la actualización de las
transacciones con monedas locales Daniel
chioli 14 de julio de 2022 Y es que
amigos amigas las reservas del Banco
Central argentino se encuentran
completamente diezmadas por lo que con
tal de no usar dólares los funcionarios
de la casa rosada están dispuestos a
echarse en brazos de cualquier otra
alternativa 25 de septiembre del 2022
diputados debaten la posibilidad de
alcanzar una moneda única con Brasil el
proyecto que apoya la creación de la
misma fue presentado por la oposición
pero cuenta con el beneplácito del
oficialismo Claro que este no parece el
mejor de Los contextos para diseñar un
programa tan serio como lo es una
unificación monetaria Así que lo siento
pero por mucho que Argentina quiera lo
normal es que Brasil por ahora quiera
echar el
[Música]
construyendo la casa por el tejado
amigos amigas América Latina es una
región socialmente muy homogénea pero
con escasos niveles de consenso
constituciones que cambian cada dos por
tres y gobiernos que suelen vender de un
hilo Y eso eso es algo que complica
mucho la idea de tener una moneda común
aunque como hayáis visto si algo
transversal a la izquierda y a la
derecha además aquí hay que tener algo
en cuenta los países estabilizan sus
economías para llevar a cabo una
unificación monetaria no unifican sus
monedas para estabilizar sus economías
que la verdad parece que es lo que
esperan la mayoría de líderes regionales
es decir en América Latina quien
defiende una moneda común parece
defenderla para enfrentarse a problemas
estructurales como La inflación Crónica
Y eso es lo mismo que empezar la casa
por el tejado Y es que tener una moneda
común como ya vimos en visual económico
en el caso del dólar puede facilitar
tener una tasa de inflación baja tasa de
crecimiento positivas y disminuir mucho
la incertidumbre y el riesgo país puede
facilitar la prosperidad Sí pero lo que
no puede hacer es garantizarla y una
moneda común que se pusiera en marcha
con tantos desequilibrios podrían hacer
condenada al fracaso De antemano Eso sí
si se fijarán normas claras una
autoridad monetaria completamente
independiente y la política monetaria se
ciñera exclusivamente al control de
precios y entonces evidentemente tanto
los ahorradores como los inversores pues
ganarían mucha seguridad jurídica pero
claro sin poder meter mano Cuántos
países realmente se mantendrían fieles a
esta moneda
sin embargo por poner una nota positiva
según un estudio publicado en febrero
del 2022 por un instituto del banco
interamericano de desarrollo 7 de cada
diez ciudadanos latinoamericanos dicen
estar a favor de que esos países se
integren más así que quién sabe Puede
que todo este deseo de crear una moneda
como un termine finalmente haciéndose
realidad y si no bueno Siempre estará el
dólar pero llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti crees que realmente veremos una
moneda común en América Latina podrían
gobiernos como el argentino superar de
una vez por toda su Adicción al Banco
Central estarían dispuestos los
políticos a renunciar por completo al
control de la política monetaria te
parece que Brasil podría liberar un
proyecto de esta clase en el corto plazo
Pues bien si os parece dejadnos por aquí
abajo vuestros comentarios y así abramos
debate Y por supuesto si este vídeo se
ha resuelto interesante no olvidéis
darle a like y suscribiros a
visualpolitik Ah y muy importante
echarle también un vistazo a nuestro
canal hermano visual económico Muchas
gracias una vez por estar ahí un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]